what i love about
ai and the way that it operates right
now is the fact that it
is unpredictable there's emergent
behavior
in our cognitively capable artificial
systems
that we can certainly model but we don't
encode directly and that's a key
difference so we like to say oh
of course this is not really intelligent
because we coded it up
and we've just put in these little
parameters there and there's like you
know
six billion parameters and once you've
learned them you know we kind of
understand the layers
but that's an oversimplification it's
it's like saying oh of course humans we
understand humans they're just made out
of neurons
and you know layers of cortex and
there's a visual
uh area and there's a but but every
human
is encoded by a ridiculously small
number of genes compared to the
complexity of our cognitive apparatus
20 000 genes is really not that much out
of which a tiny little fraction
are in fact encoding all of our
cognitive functions the rest is emergent
behavior
the rest is the you know
the the the cortical layers doing their
thing
in the same way that when we build you
know these conversational systems or
these cognitive
systems or these deep learning systems
we put the architecture in place but
then they do their thing
and in some ways that's creating
something that has its own identity
that's creating something that's not
just oh yeah it's not
the early ai where if you hadn't
programmed what happens in the
grocery bags when you have both cold and
hot and hard and
soft you know the system wouldn't know
what to do no no
you basically now just program the
primitives and then he learns from that
so even though the origins are humble
just like it is for our genetic code
for ai even though the origins are
humble the
the uh the result of it being deployed
into the world is infinitely complex
and that's and yet
there's not uh it's not yet able to be
cognizant of all the other layers in uh
of its you know it's not uh
it's not able to think about
uh space and time it's not able to think
about the hardware in which it runs the
electricity on which it runs
yet so so if you look at humans
we basically have the same cognitive
architecture as monkeys
as the great apes it's just a ton more
of it
if you look at gbt3 versus gbt2
again it's the same architecture just
more of it
and yet it's able to do so much more
yeah so if you start thinking about sort
of what's the future of that
gpt 455 do you really need fundamentally
different architectures or do you just
need a ton more hardware
and we do have a ton more hardware like
these systems are nowhere near
what humans have between our ears so
you know there's something to be said
about stay tuned
for emergent behavior we keep thinking
that general intelligence might just be
forever away but it could just simply be
that
we just need a ton more hardware and
that humans are just not that different
from the great apes
except for just a ton more of it yeah
it's interesting that in the
ai community maybe it is a human-centric
fear but the notion that gpt
10 will be will achieve general
intelligence is something that people
shy away from
that there has to be something totally
different and new added to this
and yet it's not seriously considered
that
um this this very simple
thing this very simple architecture when
scaled might
be the thing that achieves super
intelligence and people think the same
way about humanity
and human consciousness they're like oh
consciousness might be quantum or it
might be
you know some some non-physical thing
and it's like
or it could just be a lot more of the
same hardware
that now is sufficiently capable of
self-awareness
just because it has the neurons to do it
so maybe the
consciousness that is so elusive is an
emergent behavior
of you basically string together all
these cognitive capabilities
that come from running from seeing for
reacting from
predicting the movement of the fly as
you're catching it through the air
all of these things are just like great
look-up tables encoded in a giant neural
network
i mean i'm oversimplifying of course the
complexity and the diversity of the
different types of excitatory inhibitory
neurons
the waveforms that sort of shine through
the
you know the the connections across all
these different layers
the amalgamation of signals etc the
brain is enormously complex
i mean of course but again it's a small
number of primitives
encoded by a tiny number of genes which
are
self-organized and shaped by
their environment babies that are
growing up today
are listening to language
from conception basically as soon as the
auditory apparatus forms it's already
getting shaped
to the types of signals that are out in
the real world today
so it's not just like oh have an
egyptian be born and then ship them over
it's like no that egyptian would be
listening in
to the complex of the world and then
getting born and sort of seeing
just how much more complex the world is
so it's a combination
of the underlying hardware which
if you think about as a geneticist in my
view the hardware
gives you an upper bound of cognitive
capabilities
but it's the environment that makes
those capabilities shine and reach their
maximum so we're a combination of
nature and nurture the nature is our
genes
and our cognitive apparatus and the
nurture
is the richness of the environment that
makes that cognitive apparatus reach
its potential and we are so far
from reaching our full potential so far
i think that kids being born 100 years
from now
they'll be looking at us now and saying
what primitive
educational systems they had i can't
believe people were not
wired into this you know virtual reality
from birth
as we are now because like they're
clearly inferior
and so forth so i basically think that
our environment will continue
exploding and our cognitive capabilities
it's not like oh we're only using two
percent of our brain that's ridiculous
of course we're using 100 of our brain
but it's still constrained by how
complex our environment is
so the hardware will remain the same but
the software
in a quickly advancing environment the
software will make a huge difference in
the nature of like the human experience
the human condition
it's fascinating to think that humans
will look very different a hundred years
from now
just because the environment changed
even though we're still the same great
apes
the the descendant of apes
you